(rock guitar music)
- Well now it's time for
tonight's hash tag wars.
(cheering)
- [Chris] Spike.
- Silent night of the lambs.
- Yes, points.
Jessimae.
- Djingle unchained.
- Yes, points.
Djingle.
Jessimae.
- Rosemary's baby was Jesus.
- Yes, points.
No, he was opposite Jesus.
You have to say the movie.
- [Chris] Yeah, yeah. Donnell.
- 12 years an elf.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
Spike.
- Dawn of the planet of the elves.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
Donnell.
- Three French Ho hoes and a baby.
- [Chris] Points.
Spike.
- A million ways to die in a chimney.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
Donnell.
- American history X-mas.
- [Chris] Yes, points!
(cheering)
Jessimae.
- Men in black Friday.
I'm gonna kill ya for that doll!
I'm gonna kill ya for the doll!
- [Chris] Points.
Wil Wheaton.
- Megadethstar.
- Yes, points.
Brooke.
- Planet of the Drakes.
- Points.
Kevin.
- Skrillex-Wings.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
Kevin, again.
- The Clash of the titans.
- Points!
Wil.
- Castle Run DMC.
- Yes, points. So good.
Wil.
- To serve men at work.
- Yes, points.
It's a cookbook!
Kevin.
- Stephen Hawkings of Leon.
- Points.
(cheering)
Wil.
- Mos Eisley brothers.
- Yes, points.
Kevin.
- Orphan Black-eyed peas.
- Yes, points.
One time, one time.
Brooke.
- The Groots.
- Yes, points!
(cheering)
Wheaton.
Jefferson Star Trek the next generation.
(cheering)
(bell chimes)
- Alice.
- I get my friends high, and I tell them
their parents are worried about them.
- No, that's a dog, no points.
Mike Lawrence.
- I'm Jewish and the blood of Christ
won't wash from my hands.
(audience jeering)
- Braunger.
- I made all my wrapping paper
out of dick pic printouts.
- Yeah, points.
Points.
Mike.
- I design Jeff Dunham's puppets.
- You son of a bitch.
Points.
Braunger.
- I pulled off the tag on my mattress
then set it on fire with a
pile of dead hookers on top.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, that's very naughty.
Very naughty. Points.
Ah, Mike.
- I dress as Megatron
and yell at millennials.
- [Chris] Points.
Alice.
- I cast Ben Affleck as Batman.
(cheering)
(bell chimes)
- Blaine.
- Who wants these Cosby albums?
(clapping)
- Points.
Points.
Yes, Drew.
- It's a new car. Sorry.
- Points.
(bell chimes)
- [Chris] Blaine.
- Seriously, where'd that plane go?
- Points.
- [Chris] Margaret Cho.
Dat ass conquered dem titties.
(bell chimes)
- [Chris] Drew.
- Cops, what are you gonna do?
(laughing)
(clapping)
- [Chris] Margaret.
- White people should probably apologize.
- Points.
We are sorry for everything.